You guys have a lot of
samurai corps, this is me
ran Wow,
what
are
you saying, from that
tree, you can't do anything without me,
I'll do it
Even
if I'm weak or not confident
, I wonder
if it's a cure.
Now I'm
scared after I broke up with this person,
Mira alone
I was following the instructions of the mansion to protect my whereabouts.
I'm gonna be able to do it
[Music]
If you think it's a station valve, it's a generation.
Everyone's feelings
I don't want to lose an important person
You know, if you
want to protect your loved one, you have to fight now. To protect your loved one, you're the
only traitor. You're a
fool, you're incompetent and can't do anything
.
I'm weak
Then it's no good
nan
[music]
wh
car
me